Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
I am causing concern among some of our viewers
here is someone who's worried about me.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: David, I just finished watching
your video right from.
You did an interview with someone with more
subscribers, and I couldn't help but notice
wasn't the key takeaway from the video, but
it seemed like kind of pale and have like
kind of like a bag premiere.
I was wondering if with your newfound success
on your on your channel, maybe you've been
eating too much magic spoon and it's been
that night you've been using your huge mantra
more for things like blue cheese than rice.
Speaker 1: Yeah, exactly.
Now, so I actually I got so this is about
an interview I did last week, not from the
studio, but from the office.
And then I received similar emails this week
because I've been broadcasting from the bunker,
as we call it.
No, people are used to the way I look with
my studio lighting, and that lighting is very,
very powerful and professional.
And, you know, there's six lights in there
and everything's tuned not perfectly, but
it's tuned in a particular way when people
all of a sudden see me just in front of like
a white light with, you know, a technical
setup that's not as not as properly balanced,
including white balance.
I often get messages.
David, you're looking very pale.
You're looking tired.
You know, my real appearance is sort of like
the average of the way I look at all of the
different places I broadcast from.
But everything's fine.
I'm getting good sleep.
I'm, you know, taking my vitamin D, I'm doing
all of my stuff.
Everything's fine.
I appreciate the concern, but absolutely no
need to worry.
Just different lighting makes.
I also got another one saying my voice sounded
strained this week.
I'm just using a different mic.
It just sounds different.
It's just tuned a little bit differently.
The elements of audio are just slightly, slightly
different than in the studio.
So all is well.
And I appreciate the concern.
On today's bonus show, Ted Cruz and Josh Holly,
two Republican senators, suddenly they want
to break up Major League Baseball.
Is it because they've suddenly found that
we are not enforcing antitrust law that is
already on the books?
No, it's just political.
They don't like that.
Major League Baseball has protested Georgia
voting restrictions, so they want to break
up Major League Baseball.
Secondly, Canada is doing a great job of reducing
poverty and increasing equality.
We will talk about how they are doing it.
And lastly, we should be bracing for higher
grocery bills for the rest of the year.
Why and how much more expensive?
We will talk about exactly that on today's
bonus show.
You can get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at Join Pakman dot com.
You can use the coupon code if you want.
The coupon code is better twenty one and it
will save you a bundle on a membership.
And also, finally, it looks as though Joe
Biden's non State of the Union, State of the
Union has been scheduled.
Nancy Pelosi sent a letter to Joe Biden yesterday
inviting him to address a joint session of
the House and Senate on Wednesday, April 20th.
That's going to be a big night.
We will be live, live, live on YouTube, Twitch
Facebook.
We may even be live on other platforms by
then.
So mark that on the calendar.
We will be live on two weeks from today.
Joe Biden will be doing his it's not called
the State of the Union.
It will be a joint address to the Senate and
the House.
That will be two weeks from today.
I'll see you on the bonus show.
I'll see you on the live stream.
And we'll be back also, of course, with a
new show tomorrow.